okay seems like quite a nice touch by uh  alareza for rousia not starting the game  yet  they've been waiting for magnus um to  arrive so that's really  uh i mean that's showing some  sportsmanship it's a really gentlemanly  of faurusio to  uh to not rush to start that  oh i think it's the wrong way magnus  isn't it  [Laughter]  it's what happens when you're under  pressure  okay he's having a smile about it very  cool  the world champion fashionably late in  fashion  he knows the whole world is watching as  well that's uh it's hard to get dressed  when people are watching for sure  yeah will it affect him at these early  stages in the game  um for russia finally starting that yeah  i'm not really sure